are you okay pal
shouldn't we be making your show like
like right now hey you're not my boss B
yes definitely but see I get all this
research about The Witcher but I can't
seem to remember it right now hmm sounds
like you have amnesia well that does
explain all of these highly stylized
animated flashbacks I've been having
perhaps I should take this one then who
are you okay in the witcher 3 you play
as Geralt of Rivia
that's Geralt not Geralt Geralt or ever
gerald Geralt is a Witcher basically a
monster hunter for hire witches are
mutants unmatched in combat skilled in
both alchemy and magic and aren't
altogether human Geralt is the most
powerful and famous of them all this
time around Geralt is hot on the heels
of the Wild Hunt half spectral
procession half terrible omen probably
something to do with their tendency to
harvest new recruits from innocent tents
people in their alternative world they
are powerful elves called the an L but
when they travel to others like the game
world of tameria which they do via
unicorns they become wraiths like beings
the an L killed all the humans in their
world much to the annoyance of the
peace-loving unicorns who cut off their
access to other worlds in response so
now the only way the elves can cross to
other worlds is by using someone of an
ancient magical bloodline someone like
second playable character ciri my elder
blood allows me to use the gate of the
worlds to traverse time and space like
Doctor Who but with unicorns I'm not
talking about usury shut up but I love
you she was taken to the world of the an
L and required to make elder blood
babies with the king thoughts he
unfortunately died by taking too much of
an aphrodisiac
Zane Suri escaped on a unicorn back to
tameria but the an L are still hot on
her trail the wild hogs have actually
tracked dangero out in the past who they
believe will lead them to ciri as they
have a father daughter like bonds with
ciri even receiving some extensive
Witcher training if Geralt is sort of
series father then her kind of mother is
yennefer a powerful sorceress and
soulmate of Geralt no plus she can make
crows explode through the back of a
man's skull no The Witcher 3 begins with
Geralt searching for yennefer presumably
so the
find ciri to protect her from the wild
hunts because if they get their hands on
her they can invade Samaria in their
physical forms which basically spells
death for all and that's kind of it I
mean there's other stuff but how Geralt
dies at the end of the books which is
where the games kick off but then the
author doesn't really consider the games
to be canon so yes yes this is all
coming back to me now although I keep
remembering this thing and it definitely
cannot be real geralt and yennefer
boning on top of a unicorn I mean come
on
well gonna suffer an attack of explosive
amnesia did your face mate or what I
laugh